Привет. До этого момента мы работали со статичными изображениями, генерировали, искали стиль,
апскейлили, но в реальных задачах дизайнеру всё чаще нужно видео. HeroBlock на лендинге,
где продукт живёт, а не просто стоит. Какая-то короткая промо, возможно, оживление макета,
внедрение каких-то мелких анимаций, где, например, яичка твоя думает. Раньше это была отдельная
профессия с отдельным софтом, сейчас базовый видеоряд ты можешь собрать и сам. Пайплайн
видеогенерации в основном всегда один и тот же. Концепт. Что мы хотим показать? Ключевые кадры — это
опорные изображения, из которых растёт движение. Image to Video — оживляем эти самые кадры. И сборка:
склеиваем клипы в финал. Также опционально иногда добавляется звук, либо ты накладываешь его сам,
либо сразу делаешь в моделях, в которых он генерируется вместе с видео. Урок будет построен так:
сначала разберёмся, как выбирать видеомодель, чтобы это знание не устарело через месяц, потом покажу
две дороги: как сделать просто красивый ролик, а как собрать полноценное видео с консистентными
кадрами. Урок, опять же, обзорно-демонстративный, повторять каждый шаг за мной под запись не
обязательно. Мы посмотрим два варианта, вы сможете для своей домашней работы выбрать один из них.
Итак, четыре основных критерия видеомоделей. Видеомодели обновляются постоянно, запоминать
конкретные названия в целом бессмысленно. Пока ты их всех запомнишь, уже выйдет какая-нибудь новая.
Поэтому держим в голове не модели, а четыре критерия, по которым можно любую модель оценить,
и понять, она тебе подходит вообще или нет. Первый - это управляющий вход. То есть,
что ты закидываешь в неё, чтобы получить в конечном итоге своё видео. Где-то это только текст,
где-то ты можешь загрузить первый кадр, где-то можешь загрузить первый и последний кадр,
и так далее. Ну и также бывает видео-то-видео, когда ты закидываешь туда исходник и как-то его
преобразуешь. Второе - это длительность истыковка. Какой максимальной длины клип модель выдает за раз,
есть ли расширение, продление готового клипа, есть ли возможность включить бесшовную петлю.
Тоже часто нужна эта функция, мы уже видели её в Mid Journey. Можно закидывать модели в качестве первого и последнего
кадра один и тот же кадр, чтобы у нас такая петля возникала, но всё равно будет отличаться немного цветокоррекцией.
И если предусмотрена в модели возможность лупа, лучше использовать её. Третье - это аудио.
Есть ли нативное аудио, генерируется ли оно вместе с видео, есть ли липсинг. Ну, в зависимости от твоих задач,
если ты там UGC-контент какой-то генерируешь, то тебе липсинг нужен. Но в нашем контексте это вряд ли пригодится.
И последнее - это Motion Fidelity и стилистика. То, как работает вообще физика. Я думаю,
вы замечали во многих генераторах видео, что работает где-то плавно, где-то реалистично,
где-то сильно замедляется первый и последний кадр и так далее. Это тоже один из критериев,
на котором можно споткнуться при генерации. Вот в целом четыре пункта, на которые тебе нужно
обращать внимание при выборе. Мы в этом уроке посмотрим, я озвучу, какие модели под что на данный
момент лучше подходят, но они будут обновляться и это то, на что тебе стоит обращать внимание.
Теперь короткий срез того, что есть на рынке. Имена и версии будут меняться, прогоняя каждую через
те же четыре критерия.
Бео от Google, сильный универсал, хорошо слушается промпта, есть native audio, выдает высокое
разрешение. Модель хорошая. Когда нужен статичный повествовательный кадр, эта модель подходит. Эти
модели будут обновляться, выходить их новые версии. Так что, в принципе, вот это самое основное,
что есть на рынке. И для новых версий, скорее всего, те же самые описания будут подходить. Но бывает
и такое, что обновления моделей вообще меняют их вектор, открывают новые возможности, хотя и крайне
редко. Следующая модель у нас Клинк. Он силен на сложном движении, держит несколько шотов в одной сцене.
Модель на самом деле достаточно тонко настраивается, но зависит от места, где ты с ней работаешь. И самое
главное для нас - поддерживает первый и последний кадр. Именно через это мы будем делать демо.
Следующая модель Runway. Там отличный всеядный Image to Video. Можно какое угодно изображение
закинуть. Он его хорошо воспримет, сможет отстроить целое видео от него. Есть управление камерой,
консистентность персонажей, но на вход берет только Start Frame. Конечный кадр ты не задашь. Можешь только
закинуть первый кадр и описать, что там будет. Почему это важно? То есть видео у тебя может выходить
минут на пять, например. И такое модели не генерируют. Они берут по 3, по 4, по 5, по 6 секунд.
В редких случаях секунд 15. Короче, видео достаточно короткие. Если ты хочешь полноценный сценарий,
то тебе нужно их склеивать. Чтобы их склеивать, у тебя должна быть переходимость с кадра в кадр.
Не всегда один кадр в другой переходит. Да, могут быть склейки, но просто нужно иметь ввиду,
что модели, где есть только стартовый кадр, нас достаточно сильно ограничивают.
Следующая модель это C-Dance. Можно отметить тут, что она неплохо генерирует аудио вместе с видео.
Звучит там аудио достаточно достоверно. Такая, ну, нормальная средняя модель.
Также недавно вышел Gemini Omni. Генерирует быстро, генерирует прикольно. Можно скармливать несколько кадров за раз.
Короче, классная штука, но она достаточно много креативит. А что мы знаем о креативных моделях?
Что они сильно отходят от твоих указаний и добавляют что-то лишнее. Поэтому управлять ими тяжело.
Мы сегодня сравним результат, который дает она. Пока могу отметить, что результат классный, но тогда, когда ты готов нечетко следовать своему плану, своим кадрам.
Ну и отдельно также можно отметить модели Hi-Lo, One, LTX. Можно попробовать, если у тебя что-то не выходит на более дорогих моделях.
Но, как бы, это далеко не лидеры рынка, да, скажем.
Итак, ранее я сказал, что у нас есть два варианта, две дороги. Давай подробнее разверну, что я имел в виду.
Первый вариант – это как раз красивый ролик. Тебе нужен один эффектный клип. Берешь любую топовую модель и пишешь prompt или кидаешь одно изображение в image-то видео и получаешь сочный результат.
Здесь главное следить за лидерами рынка и пробовать новые модели по мере выхода. Этого хватает для большинства разовых задач.
И Google Omni лично выполняет крутой звук, классная раскадровка, работает круто, но, опять же, креативит.
Второй путь – это полноценное видео. Тебе нужна не одна красивая секунда, а сразу связанная сцена, полноценный сценарий.
Например, продукт облетает камера, несколько макетов стыкуются в единое движение.
Здесь одного promptа мало, нужна консистентность между кадрами, аккуратная стыковка клипов.
Эту дорогу держит связка. Сетка 4К для кадров, модель со старт и энд фрейм для оживления.
И в финале мы все это склеиваем. Сейчас я подробнее расскажу о том, что это такое.
Итак, сначала давай разберемся, для чего вообще вот эта 4К-сетка и прочее нужны.
Почему вообще проблема у нас с этим возникает?
Вот смотри, у нас есть JSON prompt, он достаточно четко держит стилистику, мы уже это выяснили.
Здесь мы генерировали это изображение, оно выглядит классно, тут я его попросил маленько почистить, брать текст и так далее.
У нас стилистика выражена в JSON prompt, то есть все последующие генерации должны по стилистике совпадать, мы уже это знаем.
И плюс мы делаем это в одном чате, он помнит предыдущие наши генерации.
Но если я сюда закидываю этот самый JSON prompt, прошу его сгенерировать.
Да, стилистика совпадает, да, объект похож, но здесь у нас уже другого цвета фон, немного другое освещение.
Идем дальше, просим еще раз генерировать.
Тут вообще как будто какая-то светлая комната, при том, что вроде этот текст Inter50 перенес, и в целом аппарат тоже похож.
А консистентность, она все-таки меняется.
Меняется в форме объектов, меняется в освещении, меняется в цветокоре.
Если мы, например, вот в фигме поставим их рядом, то здесь это достаточно сильно видно.
В целом, зависит от модели, где ты будешь генерировать видео, какая-то модель подстроит, какая-то будет четко следовать твоим кадрам, и это все из общей стилистики будет выбиваться.
Поэтому, что мы делаем, чтобы вся наша композиция получилась консистентной?
Мы знаем, что у нас есть стили, мудборды и прочее, можно попробовать генерировать кадры отдельно там.
Но этот стиль еще нужно обучить, короче, это долго, есть вариант проще.
И я, наверное, немного вперед забежал.
Что мы вообще сейчас делаем?
Мы отдельно генерируем кадры нашего видео.
Первый, второй, третий, как это там, например, сценаристы делают, да, они зарисовывают вот эти конкретные кадры, какое-то краткое описание дают, и потом уже по ним снимают.
Мы делаем то же самое, просто сразу готовые кадры генерируем.
У нас их может быть три, пять, десять и, в общем-то, сколько угодно.
А что нам нужно?
Нужны конкретные кадры и что между ними, ну и в них происходит.
Например, я хочу, чтобы сначала человек подошел к терминалу, что-то отсканировал, на терминале отобразилось, что все окей, принято, и затем выдался чек в этом терминале.
Вот, это мой краткий сценарий, мы сейчас еще посмотрим, как этот сценарий создать.
Соответственно, мне для него нужны три кадра.
Эти три кадра мы можем генерировать на одном холсте разом, в одной и той же стилистике.
Как видишь, я здесь сделал кучу вариантов.
Здесь каждый кадр в единой стилистике, то есть между собой, например, эти соседние отличаются, но, тем не менее, здесь один и тот же терминал,
один и тот же текст в одном и том же месте, одна и та же текстура и так далее.
То же самое касается всех остальных.
Да, здесь он немного может отступать, добавлять какой-то текст и так далее, но все это в конечном итоге можно здесь же поправить,
закинуть ему этот исходник и сказать, чувак, дорисуй, поправь.
Сделать нам это позволяет генерация в 4К.
Я использую для этого NanoBanano 2.
Она хорошо следует твоим указаниям, но при этом долю креативности добавляет.
Это для нас самый оптимальный вариант в контексте наших задач.
Итак, смотрим, какие есть соотношения и куда мы вообще можем уместить наши кадры.
Я решил, что у меня будет 3 кадра здесь для демонстрации.
Я выбрал соотношение 9 на 16 и что делаем дальше.
Добавляем фрейм.
У него можно написать здесь 900 на 1600, то есть 9 на 16, да, то же самое.
И сюда просто закинуть слайдики уже 16 на 9.
Мы знаем, что нам видео нужно в формате 16 на 9.
Ну, если в каком-то другом, то пожалуйста.
Поэтому точно так же 1600 на 900.
Все, у нас есть вот этот наш кадр.
Самое главное нам сохранить здесь соотношение.
Тут фиксируем.
И теперь, ну, сделаем его там, например, черного цвета.
И здесь умещаем на наш холст, который в итоге у нас получится там 9 на 16.
Все.
Вставляем.
Видим, что нам хватает.
Хватает с небольшим запасом.
Это важно.
Выбрать то соотношение, в которое твое количество кадров удачно поместится с минимальным запасом,
чтобы получить на каждом отдельном кадре как можно более высокое качество.
Теперь здесь выбираем.
Поставим здесь строк белого цвета.
И, ну, просто пронумеруем наши кадры, да, как я это здесь сделал.
Первый, второй, третий.
Что потом, когда мы в промпте будем говорить, в первом кадре хочу видеть это, во втором это, в третьем это,
он понимал, что куда ставить.
Вот.
Получается у нас такая штука.
И мы эту штуку прикрепляем вместе с нашим промптом.
Вот так это выглядит.
Вот промпт.
Вот изображение.
Все.
Запускаем.
Получаем кадры.
Затем промпт.
Сейчас покажу, как получить.
После того, как ты загенерировал эти изображения, тебе нужно их правильно вставить.
У тебя будет 4К изображение, и 4К изображение в фигму не вставляется.
Он автоматически его ресайзит до разрешения поменьше.
Нам этого не нужно.
Нам нужно, чтобы у нас в 4К вставилось изображение.
Поэтому мы используем плагин.
Плагин называется Insert Big Image.
Запускаем его.
Выбираем изображение, которое хотим вставить.
Все.
Он вставляет наше изображение.
Вставляет он его вот отдельно кусками, для того, чтобы присайзить не пришлось.
После чего мы берем Slice.
Slice также ставим 1600 на 900.
Нам нужен кадр 16 на 9.
Закидываем сюда и растягиваем, сколько нам нужно.
Подгоняем под наш кадр, который у нас тут получается.
И нажимаем экспорт.
Экспортируем.
Называем, например, там, не знаю, Screen 1.
Таким же образом.
Просто перетягиваем сюда ниже.
Экспортируем Screen 2.
Перетягиваем ниже.
Экспортируем Screen 3.
Все.
Максимально консистентные, в максимально высоком разрешении у нас есть кадры.
Если вдруг у тебя кадров очень много, ты на одном холсте их сгенерировал,
мы уже знаем, что такое Upscale.
Знаем, как что нам Upscale, поэтому закидываем туда.
С этим тоже проблем возникнуть не должно.
И дальше мы из этого генерируем видео, закидываем эти кадры и так далее.
Но пока давай посмотрим, как я вообще получил этот промпт.
Я, как обычно, подготовил для тебя директиву,
которая сразу тебе выдаст все, что нужно для генерации видео.
Еще раз обмолвлюсь, что то, что я сейчас показал, это нормальный, хороший подход,
где у тебя отдельно каждый кадр.
Ты можешь его редактировать, ты их потом склеиваешь и не режешь видео.
Есть также второй подход, когда ты просто закидываешь один кадр,
просто закидываешь текст или закидываешь сразу несколько кадров.
И текстовое описание, и модель сама генерирует.
Под оба этих принципа директива рассчитана под оба этих пути.
Мы сейчас симулируем с нуля.
Поэтому просто придумай сам вот эту комбинацию и выдай мне результат.
Директива будет называться Video Storyboard.
Как обычно, ее вызываем.
И в первую очередь он спросит у тебя, у тебя есть уже идея для ролика,
или ты хочешь, чтобы он сам ее сгенерил.
Возможно, в голову сейчас ничего не приходит, такое бывает.
Пускай сам придумает, исходя из нашего продукта, стилистики и прочего,
описания и кадров, и видео, которые должны получиться.
А мы это просто заберем.
Итак, он сгенерировал нам Storyboard, исходил с Job to be done Антона,
что он хочет быстро поднять сервер и забыть.
Здесь он постарался в этом видосе отразить скорость.
Ну, забавно, да, что у нас все здесь вместе.
Насколько это реально будет работать на человека.
Здесь, конечно, можно еще поискать маркетинговые скиллы,
скормить ему какие-нибудь учебники по сценарному искусству и так далее.
Но сейчас у нас нет задачи снимать полнометражное кино.
Давай почитаем, что он здесь нам собрал.
Описал концепт, описывает якорь сцены, что у нас здесь происходит.
Итак, здесь в директиве я указал, что должно быть три кадра.
Если ты хочешь больше кадров, то заранее ему об этом скажи.
Здесь первое, что он генерирует, это в JSON формате описание отдельно каждого фрейма.
Frame 1, Frame 2, Frame 3.
Можешь сгенерировать их отдельно, если есть такое желание, если ты используешь стили.
Либо, если хочешь воспользоваться методом сетки, что я советую тебе делать,
есть отдельный промпт, в котором описано все, в котором в одном месте сказано,
что у нас есть уже готовая сетка и она будет прикреплена к запросу.
И расписано, что на каждом из секторов будет происходить.
Дальше у нас Transitions, то есть переходы.
Есть три кадра, соответственно, между ними два перехода.
Из первого во второй, из второго в третий.
Клип А, первый клип, из фрейма первого во фрейм второй.
Здесь описание того, что должно происходить.
Клип Б.
И промпт для всего видео, когда ты разом все скрины закидываешь
и просишь за один раз это все собрать.
Давай посмотрим, как это работает, где это делать
и какой получается результат при разном подходе.
Ну, во-первых, для генерации визуала нам нужен Grid Prompt.
Просто копируем его.
Возвращаемся в Крию.
Здесь у меня Grid уже прикреплен, эту картинку.
Ну, я думаю, ты и сам в силах прикрепить.
Вставляем промпт.
9 на 16.
И ты можешь сразу в 4К не генерировать,
потому что иногда он делает что-то не то.
Вот, например, здесь.
Мне понравилось, как он сделал раскадровку.
Ну, здесь он вот этот QR-код в качестве стикера прилепил.
Это как-то выглядит не очень надежно.
Плюс добавил сюда текст.
И сразу как бы сгенерировал это в 4К.
Потратил мое время, потратил токены.
Ты можешь генерировать просто в 1К разрешение,
а потом апскейлить до 4К.
Закидываем в 1К.
И он сейчас быстренько нам сгенерирует это изображение.
Все.
Собрал нам раскадровку.
Мне больше нравится первое.
Кстати, прям стильно выглядит.
Супер.
Забираем.
Это изображение в 1К очень низкого разрешения,
поэтому это все можно отсюда удалить.
Мне вот эта штука понравилась.
Закидываю сюда.
Просто сделай апскейл.
И ставлю здесь 4К.
Можно делать таким образом.
Если не хочешь тратить много токенов,
париться с настройкой апскейлера,
просто можно через нано-бананы это делать.
Я так частенько делаю.
Я решил еще апскейл сделать через магнифик.
Просто посмотреть, какой будет результат.
И, честно говоря, он мне нравится больше.
Потому что он добавил здесь
каких-то более интересных отражений.
Хотя и вот здесь, например,
сильно испортил текст.
Все-таки это креативная модель.
Но четкость тут прямо очень высокая.
Итак, про апскейлили наши изображения.
Теперь, что мы делаем дальше?
Теперь мы режем на кадры, как я ранее показал.
И эти кадры будем закидывать при генерации видео.
Мы знаем, где у нас тут находится вкладка видео.
Здесь я советую выбрать Клинк.
Потому что у него есть первый и последний кадр.
Плюс относительно остальных моделей
он здесь стоит недорого.
Всего 250.
А результат дает нормальный.
Но, конечно, есть и покруче модели.
Как минимум Клинк 3.0, а не O3,
который я здесь использовал.
Он в два раза дороже, но при этом круто работает.
Также в Сиденс последний можно закидывать стартовый и конечный кадр.
Но сейчас, просто чтобы много токенов не сжигать,
быстро попробовать, можно использовать Клинк O3.
Выбираем его.
Ставим длительность видео.
Я ставил 3 секунды, чтобы максимально быстро все было.
И закидываем сюда изображение.
Нам нужно закинуть первый кадр и следующий после него.
Поэтому выбираем наш первый кадр, выбираем второй и закидываем описание того, что между ними происходит.
Где у нас это описание нам его сгенерировал Клод.
Вот наш транзишн.
Копируем, возвращаемся, вставляем и запускаем генерацию.
Мое первое видео выглядело так.
Все, у нас плавный переход с первого на второй кадр.
Все максимально аккуратно выглядит.
Максимально аккуратно и максимально предсказуемо, что важно.
Дальше то же самое проделываем со следующими двумя кадрами.
Тот, который был у нас последним в прошлый раз, становится первым.
И третий кадр догружаем.
Генерируем видео между вторым и третьим кадром.
Здесь у нас выезжает чек, что у нас прошла оплата успешно.
Все, супер.
Можно генерировать еще.
Можно здесь, нажав Add Audio, добавить звук.
Но сразу говорю, что так себе здесь внутри он добавляет звук.
Он добавляет просто как будто с конференции какие-то голоса.
Непонятных людей никак это не соотносится с тем, что происходит на экране.
Поэтому этой штукой смысла пользоваться нет.
Так что ты можешь использовать Extend, чтобы продолжить это видео.
Но здесь у нас доступно только описание без изображения.
То есть мы не можем здесь определить последний кадр.
Соответственно, использовать это я особо смысла не вижу.
Итак, есть у нас два видео.
Мы нажимаем Download, скачиваем их.
И переходим в любой инструмент для монтажа видео.
Если ты работаешь на Mac, у тебя есть уже iMovie, в котором это можно сделать совершенно бесплатно.
Если у тебя винда, то ты можешь скачать отдельно CapCut.
Это полностью бесплатное приложение для монтажа.
Открываем CapCut и сюда закидываем наши видео.
Давай посмотрим с самого начала, как это сделать.
Новый проект.
Выбираем эти наши два видео, которые мы скачали.
И просто их сюда на дорожку закидываем.
Все.
Можно развернуть на весь экран, посмотреть, что у нас получается.
Пользователь прикладывает.
Бесшовный переход.
Конец и начало вот этих вот стыков можно подрезать, чтобы у нас динамичнее переход происходил.
Но здесь, если подрезаешь, то становится видно маленько, что у нас стык.
Поэтому имей в виду.
Все.
Таким образом мы можем генерировать какое угодно количество кадров.
Склеивать это все хоть в полнометражные фильмы.
Главное, чтобы тебе токенов хватило.
Но.
Что если я хочу быстро, креативно и не хочу запариваться с этим всем?
Здесь у нас второй вариант.
Мы знаем, что у нас.
Агент сгенерировал еще и whole video prompt.
Промпт для всего видоса.
Просто копируем его и идем в Gemini.
Здесь в Gemini давай запустим новый чатик.
Дожмем плюсик.
Сгенерировать видео.
Он сразу говорит, творите с Omni.
Закидываем три наших кадра.
Чтобы он на них ориентировался по композиции хотя бы.
Желательно ставить их в том порядке, в каком ты хочешь генерировать это видео.
Я закинул ему те три кадра, которые мы вместе делали.
Закинул prompt, который мне создал Клод.
И все.
Он переходит к генерации видео.
Давай сразу посмотрим.
У нас уже есть отдельно кусками по кадрам сгенерированное видео.
Давай посмотрим, на что способен он при полной творческой свободе.
Итак.
Вот один из вариантов.
Я несколько сгенерировал.
Есть звук.
Есть очень реалистичное вот это пошатывание чековой ленты.
У нее классная текстура.
Но здесь поменялось освещение.
Поменялась фактура самих предметов.
Как бы вроде как он следует тому, что задумано.
Но тут какой-то цех завода появился на фоне.
Здесь вот этот замочек, который сильно удешевляет сам терминал.
Как будто это просто какой-то в подъезде ящик.
И принцип был в том, что он сканирует QR-код, а не просто телефон прикладывает.
Получилось прикольно.
Получилось со звуком.
Получилось быстро.
Но с определенными нюансами.
Посмотрим еще один вариант с ровно теми же вводными.
Здесь он опять как-то странно прикладывает.
Переход соблюден.
Ну и также печатается чек.
То есть плюс-минус по композиции то же самое.
Он берет за основу эти кадры, но все-таки их дорабатывает.
Добавляет здесь также фон.
Можно помучить его.
Можно более точно добавить сюда промпт.
Но ты должен понимать, что это креативная модель.
Она делает сама, делает быстро, делает круто.
Поэтому контролировать ее сложно, как это обычно бывает.
И посмотрим, что он сейчас сгенерировал по идее Клода.
Потому что я даже ее не читал.
Мне интересно, что он такое придумал.
Я, честно, не понял, что здесь происходит.
Он приложил какой-то реквизишн.
Судя по всему, он должен был сначала его взять.
Потом засунуть куда-то.
Потом напечататься чек.
Видос как минимум цепляет.
Он интересный.
Его еще немного доработать.
И будет вообще круто.
И отдельно еще по поводу звука.
Да, в первой вариации его не было, потому что мы использовали такую модель.
Здесь ты уже можешь сам добавлять, например, в капкате какие угодно звуки, музыку и прочее.
Все из открытой библиотеки.
Но учитывая, что вот где у нас здесь вот эти фиолетовые алмазики, это платный звук.
Это только на премиум подписке.
Вот какой-то Chill Lounge Journey.
Можно добавить.
Все, уже со звуком.
Точно так же здесь есть звуки, ну не только музыкальные, но еще и звуковые эффекты.
Какой-то там смех, аплодисменты, звук чековой ленты, переходы и так далее.
Все это здесь есть в библиотеке.
Но это уже такое звукорежиссерство.
Это не быстро, это не просто.
Поэтому, если есть желание, это можно делать тут.
Но можно просто чуть больше токенов пожечь на моделях с генерацией звука сразу из коробки.
Итак, что мы сегодня узнали?
У нас есть точный путь и есть быстрый путь.
Точный путь, это более, можно сказать, даже с точки зрения режиссуры, классический вариант.
Сначала у тебя есть раскадровка, есть понимание, что происходит между сценами.
Закидываем поэтапно, склеиваем, получаем наше кино.
Когда твой ролик, скорее всего, будет коротким, когда тебе не так важно, чтобы все там было консистентно, все было ровно так, как ты задаешь, можно использовать его.
Gemini Omni сейчас отлично с этим справляется, поэтому там, где нужна скорость и там, где ты готов к креативу модели, можно выбирать ее.
Итак, в качестве домашней работы тебе нужно сделать одно видео для своего продукта.
Директивы, как обычно, будут под этим уроком.
Запускаешь ее, он дает тебе раскадровку, кадры, либо с ней вместе брейнштормишь, либо берешь то, что она тебе дает.
Генерируем видос либо поэтапно с сеткой в клинге, затем склеиваем, либо просто по-быстрому в Gemini Omni.
Еще один момент, если у тебя не получается зайти в Gemini, такое тоже бывает, по умолчанию он закидывает тебя через аккаунт Google, который у тебя выставлен в качестве по умолчанию.
По умолчанию он у тебя выставлен, если ты в хроме авторизировался через него.
Поэтому здесь добавляем профиль с твоим дополнительным купленным аккаунтом, у меня это уже сделано, выбираем его и здесь переходим на Gemini, Google Gemini.
Все, он автоматически меня закидывает уже в мой аккаунт.
И здесь никаких других больше нет.
После того, как ты видео собрал, скачиваешь его и закидываешь себе на Google диск, на Яндекс диск, на Mail.ru диск, еще куда тебе удобнее.
Главное, чтобы его можно было открыть по ссылке.
Обязательно проверь, что у тебя настройки приватности установлены, что доступ открыт для всех и можно будет его посмотреть.
На этом все.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания.
До встречи в следующем уроке.